Edith had the brilliant costume designer
once said a dress should be tight enough
to show you're a woman and loose enough
to prove you're a lady she won eight
Oscars the most of any costume designer
in history let's find out now who's on
the road to giving Miss Edith a run for
her money
here are the nominees for achievement in
custom design anonymous costume design
by lizzie crystal the artist
costume design by mark bridges hugo
costume design by Sandy Powell Jane Eyre
costume design by Michael O'Connor w/e
costume design by Ariane Phillips and
the Oscar goes to mark bridges the
artist
for the artist designer mark purchase
chose certain colors to help the
author's liven up the scene even though
the film was then converted to black and
white this is his first Academy Award
Wow this is thrilling
I want to thank Michel Hazanavicius for
making a beautiful film and having me
along for the ride
Thomas Langman for believing in the film
and getting the resources together to
make it and Harvey Weinstein and The
Weinstein Company for getting it out to
the world um I want to thank my
wonderful crew and you know I was just a
kid from Niagara Falls who dreamed ate
and slept movies and so I want to thank
the Academy for this honor and for
making a lifelong dream come true thank
you